مين الدوحه ينضم الينا مراسل صباح العربيه
ليله البازاري ليث وين ما كنت بنقول لك يا
زينه عيشتك كيف عيشه اجواء مباراه
السعوديه بولندا امس
عشت رياضيه اليوم يا سهام صباح الخير لكم
يعني قبل ما نحكي عن الاجواء الرياضيه راح
نحكي عن الاستاذ ههه
ملاعب الموجوده عندنا ستاد البيت بيت
الشعر اللي بنشوفه خلفي الذي يتسع الى
60,000 متفرج واستضاف المباراه الشهيره
الافتتاحيه بين قطر والاكوادور في
المجموعه الاولى يقع في مدينه الخور وليست
الدوحه استاد احمد بن علي التسالي 40,000
متفرج ويقع في مدينه ام الافاعي واستاد
الجنوب واستاد خليفه الاول واستاد المدينه
التعليميه
الديوكيشن ستلعب فيها المنتخب السعودي ضد
بولندا امبارح واستاد له السيد وستاد 74
الثمامه الذي سيستقبل اليوم الفريق
المغربي ضد المنتخب المغربي عفوا ضد همم
بلجيكا واذا حكينا عن الاجواء يعني عن جد
كانت اجواء كثير كثير حماسيه
كاس العالم 2018
كرواتيا وفرنسا بتذكر اذكر تماما كيف كان
الوضع كرواتيا بس انه ال ال اللي شفناه
امبارح كان مهيب يعني عجبني اكثر شيء
التنظيم كيف الشباب السعودي والعائلات
السعوديه كانت تاتي عبر مع برشلونه يوصلوا
بالحافلات اييه قدام الحافلات قدام
الموجوده كانت تنقلهم مباشره من المناطق
السعوديه الى قطر
لمشاهده المباراه والحلو بالموضوع انه كيف
كان التنظيم يعني هلا كثير منهم طلعوا من
ساعات الفجر الاولى من المناطق السعوديه
تتخيل الشخص اجى من القصيم همم لينتقل الى
الدوحه لحضور هذه المباراه ان كانت رائع
مثل ما حكيته قبل شوي كانت يعني المباراه
المنتخب السعودي لعب بطريقه عن جد رائعه
تفضلي
طيب انت جيت من فرنسا يعني شعرت انه في
وجود فرنسي واضح لدعم الديوك الفرنسيه في
المونديال خصوصا في مباراه امس
يا نادين
كلهم اجوا كان في كثير بفوز
عليه انت مع البلوشي شكلك
اول امبارح كان في برده همم مغاربه جايين
من انحاء اوروبا اللي يشجعوا المنتخب
المغربي الذي سيلعب اليوم على مثل ما
حكينا على السادس ضد الفريق المنتخب
البلجيكي وشفنا كمان جنسيات اخرى ما بنسى
كيف كان بالطياره معنا الكلارز لابسين كل
كل حاجه لابس منتخب منتخب فريقه فكانت
مقاعد الطائره كانها امواج من الالوان
احمر ابيض
مباريات بين المنتخب وسط الدوحه موجوده
اللؤلؤه موجود سوق واقف شاشات عرض كبيره
غير الفانزونس انتبهوا بتلاقي ال يعني
عجبني كيف الروح الرياضيه بين المشجعين
كيف بيكونوا موجودين جنب بعض مع انهم
فريقين وتنافسين في كاس العالم وبيلعبوا
مرات يعني شفنا السعوديه وبولندا موجودين
جنبا الى الملعب بحكي عن المناطق التي
تقام فيها
الاحتفالات والشاشات التي تعرض همم
المباريات فهذا شيء جميل يعني روح رياضيه
بمئه بالمئه في هذا البلد العربي قطر وان
شاء الله يكون النجاح عربي في بلد عربي
وكاس عربي ان شاء الله كل التوفيق
للمنتخبات العربيه والمغرب اليوم من
الدوحه شكرا جزيلا صباح العربيه دائما